今年好多访问里面有提到
你没有那么排斥甜心的这样的一个人设和形象
我觉得很大的重点是因为他不是我的人设
他是我的个性特质之一
我觉得不管别人理不理解你
你都可以喜欢自己
拥抱自己的特质
因为环境的关系
我是长姐
我是姐姐
然后有一个小我五岁的弟弟
所以从小就是会比较独立的做事情
而且我爸妈就是离异的状态嘛
所以有时候就要变小妈妈
我觉得我没有一个一定要强娶什么的心
可是我真的就是我做好我每一份我该做的事情
然后我就是用一个我不能丢脸的心情去做好
我该做的每一件事情
不止甜
我乘风破浪
20年一起来
欢迎在华人圈大家公认的浪姐第一名
欢迎新年
欢迎华晨好
欢迎欢迎
谢谢谢谢呵呵呵
很开心见到你
欢迎你
新不新来
是我们今天全部换成粉红色的
然后我说怎么多了这么多的糖果哦
其实是呃就是浪姐的奖杯就对了
对
是当时的奖杯
我就觉得很像那个一个游戏
我以前一直在玩这个游戏
植物大战僵尸的游戏的奖杯
我就觉得百花齐放
所以也很谢谢心灵
因为应该是我们第一次可以看到这个奖杯
这么的cute哦
其实王心凌现象
那当然也是一种怀旧现象
你想过说你会带动一个现象
所以我从来也真的是没有想过这件事情
然后我就其实我们就是我自己觉得
我就是尽力去做好我该做的每一份工作对
然后所以那时候有出现这样的现象的时候
其实我自己也是完全没有想到
也是蛮压抑的
而且这个现象不是说就停在2022
2023啊
王心凌要开演唱会哦
那这整个演唱会也是大家对于这个现象里面的
再次回温
包括初舞台三天内七条热搜
全网热搜指数高达46.34
然后这个一定要讲
你一票我一票
王心凌80还唱跳话题热度
这个话题就是757.7万
然后节目演唱爱你的
单支影片播放量是高达730万次哇
所以这么高的热度
这样的热度持续的时候
其实那时候你还在竞赛
对我还在竞赛
我当时还在比赛三公的比赛里头
所以我只是嗯因为都是摄影机嘛
我只是回到化妆间的时候
然后终于有一点点时间他们在补妆
然后拿起手机嗯嗯有这么多呃
微博热搜有这么多这这么多的话题
我我我自己很惊讶
可是其实我在当下
其实也是没有时间消化的
只能说很开心
然后呃就很有动力再继续努力
但这个现象里面还有一个
我觉得它代表的是我
我觉得应该是浪姐的节目制作
但是他会很高兴
因为他本来就是观察
而且唤起了一个情怀
然后情怀我现在告诉大家说
其实这不只是怀旧
因为他们还在
现在我们来看一下这一个啊这一个影带
然后再继续跟心理描情话
多说一点
想我就多给一都是我的感觉
萌萌的
结果看见你把你想说目前的一切天气
今天又没电了
我天男孩请求一战
就是有我常烦着你好美月中多少人梦想拥
爱就是有我常烦着你
Oh baby
情话
我想跟那些粉丝说
如果他们可以看到心凌现在在看这个视频表情
他们会觉得很安慰
因为我们看了哈哈哈
大笑也是心灵是一个很专注
而且好像在欣赏和分享的感觉
你看到这么多人因为这一首歌
然后重新pick up
刚有个是某人的太太录的
对不对
他说我现在在听这首歌的表情
那还有人好像他回到了那个时代
对我看到这些视频的时候
其实这些视频也在呃
我那时候宿舍很忙碌的在工作
就是睡前在放松的时刻
就是在划的这些视频
我觉得这些视频呢常常歌迷都会说呃
我的歌带给他们一些什么温暖
我觉得这个视频也在当时
带给忙碌的我的一种抚慰
然后有很多呃王心凌男孩
就像有那我还有看过在洗头的
正在洗头的爸爸
然后呃看听到王心凌的歌
然后就冲到客厅
然后是正在煮菜的家庭主妇
这样就拿着锅铲就冲到客厅
其实也有很多王心凌女孩
也有一些就是她整个模仿copy
我原本的爱你的这个MV的视频
然后从每个角度啊
甚至他扮演我跟王少伟
就是其实就是他们都花了很多时间
去做这个影片
其实我非常的感动
也非常的谢谢
就是这样一个双向奔赴
就是我的歌曲带给他们温暖
带给他们回忆
然后他们的这些视频也带给我很多力量吧
可能在那时候很忙的时候
看到这些视频真的心情会比较轻松
所以我觉得这是网络时代
对艺人来讲一个很不容易的流动
对不对
我们来看一下关于王心凌现象里面的经济现象
这就是我讲的王心凌现象变成经济现象
哈哈这个芒果超媒的股票是在初舞台播出四天
股票长了啊
ten percent哦
这个涨幅是很惊人的
这个超美股票的这个涨势
其实是应该是投资大众
从他直播这档节目
从这个心理女孩的现象发现说
唉如果我们传媒能够让大家对于以前美好时光
能够重温
从以前得到现在的力量的话
那这个传媒他们认为应该是抓对了趋势
跟大家的心理需求
你对这个心理需求其实不止在浪姐之前
你有没有渐渐的感觉到怀旧美好
这个我觉得就是可能感动的事情
有时候10年20年也不会变对
然后也许怀旧美好
会带给我们一种就是比较放松
一种安抚的感觉
也许他可以带我们暂时远离生活上的一种压力
或者是紧张和不安
让我们重温了过去曾经美好的情感跟那种快乐
所以我真的很感恩爱你
对很多人来说是有这样子的存在
然后跟当时的一些气氛和环境
我想也是有点关系
那我可以问一下说
我们该不会把爱你
放在今年演唱会的uncle去吧
啊哈哈
很难说
但是就是一定一定会有这一首歌
但是在什么点
我们真的是有好好想过对
所以这不能辜负已经抢到演唱会票的这个听友
我们不能在这边宣布
因为他们就要坐在里面对
怀着期待的心情
其实他自己猜对了没有
其实我自己对于这场演唱会我也是倍感压力
这一圈下回放是夜空
在石头下有信号
坐在巨型娃娃机吊爪上的是甜蜜教主王心凌
而信念如一日的美少女姿态也人如其名
印在衣服上
美少女美少女
你的衣服美少女啦
就是尽量保持美少女的心情
年纪日渐增长
这个疲劳这件事情还是会发生
所以导演麻烦你开拍快一点
MV片场布置着缤纷的色彩
指导MV的是经常和5月天蔡依林合作的阿木
导演陈奕仁
我第一次得金曲奖的时候
自然心里颁给我的
所以姐姐是不是来报恩的感觉
不是一口嗯对
因为我拍过很多明星嘛
其实有时候大家就想说哎是我们出道了一阵子
然后就是哎我们这样转变形象这样
而我们这次走的一个讨论是
既然已经是甜心教主
那我们就这次填到底
然后实际上合作以后就是甜到爆炸
他其实是很蛮贴心的女生这样
然后她在工作的时候
其实都会照顾到所有工作人员的感受
一首歌不同角度要重复排数十次MV呈现
不过短短56分钟
却是现场近百名工作人员全力合作
一天一夜完成的作品
作为主角的王心凌停机时也不能休息
这支舞其实算是真的是我的专辑的快歌
风格比较不一样
好舞蹈强度真的是比较难的
一次为你如果带着那种可以看心跳的那种手表
没有我们练舞的时候心跳都可以到一百五百六
像我们刚才不是有一整排GOPRO吗
还好他好放一整排
不然每一集一次的话不知道多少次
二一请起来
宣布演唱会的记者会上
王心凌久违的面对媒体
要迈上41岁的她
让大家惊叹的是纤瘦又结实的身材
就是比我的年纪再低一点嗯
哇那也才二十二十嘛
到28吧
我骗人哇
这帮甜诶对
所以是
但是OK我一直也没有避讳年轻
点一首歌给honey甜言蜜语
出道20年
被封为甜蜜甜心教主
人人称羡的外貌与好身材
也是付出努力运动与保养
我本来就是圆圆的脸
这脸没有不会太伤了
就是我说该运动的
我还是还是保持部分
就是就是再累
我还是会push自己去矜持有度
总是拿出最好表现的
她回顾刚出道时盯着日系唱跳美少女
与当时已经走红的蔡依林有着类似的路线
许巍原是当时爱会唱片的主管
回忆起当时打造王心凌抓到艺人本职
原来才是关键
为什么却花了那么多钱买的衣服
做的造型
她明明就是一个那么漂亮的女生
可是一直都觉得好像哪里不对
在拍
当你的这首MVMV已经第四部了
然后张敏导演就说
哎你可以带你们的高中制服来
你那时候差不多20岁左右
就还是很很无违和感
他皮肤那么白
那私底下其实很自然
你有没有什么歌啊
我想拍一个就是以学生为主
因为我觉得他很像日系的学生
黄中平导演从王心凌出道至今
和他合作过22支音乐录影带
这些打造成功艺人的军师们
抓到王心凌的甜美特质
发扬光大经典传唱的爱你也是由中平导演长进
Baby
情话多说一点
想我就多看一眼
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
既然我们那时候花了那么多钱做造型
都觉得没有找到一个很对的方向
对那这这张开始我该穿
让他穿制服
所以之后在爱你的里面就把这件事情发扬光大
我永远都记得那一天他那个歌
第一个她就很甜美
第一个我们在工作现场
真的每个人都很开心
每个东西好像都对了
孙俪超过38年的黄中平导演
看过形形色色的明星
面对刚出道的王心凌
也找到一套方法拍出属于王心凌的镜头语言
我第一次跟他工作的时候
发现他非常的紧绷
所在颈椎里
他处女座怕脏啊
然后怕这个那个对齐癖之类的
可当你都准备好时
你就拍他的时候发现嗯
他没有没有办法更多了
我会弄乱他的节奏
所以每次快快快快快快快
慢慢慢慢慢慢慢慢慢慢
你要把他节奏弄乱了以后
而且到了后面做一件拍一个东西
拍的到后面说他是最好
出道后的爆红唱片偶像剧双七忙碌的演艺工作
到了30岁
暂时缓下脚步
减少发片量与演戏
但是当2020年
全世界进入疫情时代
大陆实境节目乘风破浪的姐姐兴起
王心凌2022年参与第三季
那个爱你的王心凌
重新唤醒观众的记忆
其实我觉得很自然
我那时候是定制的衣服嘛
然后后面啊
因为演唱会其实也会表表演到爱你这首歌
那时候去浪姐的时候在表演
因为是要表演爱你这首歌嘛
其实就是想要把呃原本的这个
当时大家对于我在爱你的这个美好的样子
就是带给大家在音乐里面有一些人的事
我可能100年1000年都不会变的
是会被喜爱的
当然最重要的是心灵
他没有变
王心凌在乘风破浪的姐姐
除了开场表演制造了惊人的网络效应
后续的表现稳扎稳打
尤其被推举当队长时
更是展现出过人的稳重与责任心
这股独立又照顾人周到的个性
也如同他在演艺圈鸭子划水般不强出头
默默的努力
好喜欢这个形容
我其实我自己在在水上面是漂亮的天鹅在
但其实这一场
因为我们真的一路也有那演唱会嘛
这样我真的是还蛮自律的
在保持自己的体能的状态
也因为这样子
所以后来去参加节目的时候
相对来说还是比较可以应付的
嗯带孩子觉得很累
自律会带来更大的自由
这样的王心凌在浪姐被看见
努力与实力
爱你的制服少女甜美依旧更长
成了40岁的智慧与美丽
王心凌的乘风破浪
来的正是最好的时光
当我们回顾很快就要回顾这20年的时候
我们切分成20多岁
30多岁
然后到今年开20年的这个演唱会
才发现很难定位你
你之前你会演戏嘛
然后歌手哦
但是有其他不同的发展啊
151首歌诶
所以这次演唱会大家大概嗯嗯就算组曲
大概也也也没有办法容纳一半就对了
嗯就算有组曲
应该最多也是30几首歌
可能40首也没有办法装得下
到昨天还在跟经纪人
还在battle某一首歌到底要放哪一首
这样你觉得在这个阶段里面是不是30
他是一个很重要的阶段
让你自己对于自己要选择什么
然后同时你的选择权在市场上
或者是在一般粉丝的心中去验证出来
你对他们的了解是对的
是在这个阶段
小时候是没有时间停下来生活的
也没有跟家人朋友相处的时间
30岁产业的变化
发批量没有像这个时候
2005年连发三张专辑
销售破百万
但重点是一年连发三张
而且我这中间还拍戏
拍的这部戏吧
我刚刚我们还有同仁在想说
你有没有看我有看到这一幕
超好笑的哦
所以收视率6.61
打破当年台湾偶像剧所有的记录
对当时我觉得就是一个很密集
然后很很全盛的一个时期
这样这个时候wake可不可以说就你的人生来讲
其实它是一个先生存
然后再发展的阶段
所以这属于是一个努力生存的阶段
的确是的确是
而且他奠定了很多我后面的从容自在
那我们都会好奇
为什么后来你会接受大型竞赛节目的挑战
就是挑战来的时候
当时你是怎么判断的
然后点头
我觉得因为疫情疫情的关系
其实让我
我跟很多各地的歌迷
就是见面的机会变少了很多
这样那因为疫情两年
大家停滞了两年
其实很单纯的
真的是觉得说好像应该要有一些不一样的舞台
好像要有更多可以跟歌迷见面的
这个这个这样的机会
现在是第3年
所以那时候展开了我人生中第一次隔离
21天
我第一次隔离21天进大陆就是21天
那个时候
因为那个时候
因为疫情可能还是在一个第几阶段的高峰期
所以我们一进去就隔离21天
21天结束之后
我就只对他一生都很难忘
因为他刚好重复了五次
21天
对我从来没有在家这样子待过21天
所以那20天你都做些什么
大家一定很好奇哦
21天刚好
那时候准备出舞台的爱你
我的编曲
我的编舞
然后我的练舞我都是在那个房间玩完成
在那个时候有没有你自己的声音
或是你旁边啊
你很信任了解你的人
曾经跟你说NO
就说要不要参加这个大型竞赛
可以再考虑一下
我的经纪人
当时的确有迟疑了一下
他迟疑迟疑了一下
觉得说的确可以再观望一下
尤其像第一季其实很实际的啦
我觉得这个都可以理解
但我觉得有时候就是上天安排好的
我觉得这个timing也许我第三季才去
这个是最适合的
当我们考虑要不要投入一个竞赛时
我们通常是怕输
就是如果十拿九稳的话
那么我就很容易say yes
那时候你对于啊这个名次这件事
当你决定投入的时候
他们曾经在你心里面变成一个一个因素
还是没有
其实没有
我从来没有想过说我要去推广坤丢光棍台跟白
我没有这样想
可是我只有默默的跟金钱讲说
我们应该会成团吧
就是既然要去的话
至少应该也要成团吧
所以我真的就是我们在那里面
其实就是我觉得我没有一个
一定要强娶什么的心
可是我真的就是我做好我每一份我该做的事情
然后我就是用一个我不能丢脸的心情
去做好我该做的每一件事
其实我觉得浪姐冠军王心凌现在留给我们
可以一直激励的
就是这一个就是那个态度跟精神
不管
5278加加加加欢迎新春来爱你
就算正值暑假期间
王心凌一回到母校华冈艺校
仍然受到学弟妹列队欢迎
好你们现在的科室有哪几种
戏剧课演演艺科
演艺科分两组
音乐组跟歌舞剧组
然后还有一个舞蹈歌
就这样
我们我们一小时后呢
是国西舞聚美国乐西乐舞蹈
戏剧美术B20多年重返校园
很多风景和人事物都变了
上方还特别在校园里各个led灯都打上
欢迎王心凌字样
那你有注意到有啊有注意到
让我们掌声
欢迎23届戏剧科校友王心凌返回母校录
有点lonely
因为现在是暑假哈哈现在是暑假
如果不是暑假的话
我完全可以想象有多热闹
华冈艺校的高三小学弟担任起校园向导
一路上王心凌也跟我们聊着他的高中回忆
我本人以前是牛奶学姐
因为我很白
很多人不知道我叫什么名字
然后可是就会叫牛奶学姐
然后以前我们也有同学就在这边
因为没有这个嘛
然后就在这边表白
小白
不是谁谁
我喜欢你的
对对对面讲的
因为学校就这么大
这么自行的
所以你就可以站在这边对大家讲
三栋楼组成的华冈艺校位在阳明山上
校地范围不大
甚至没有一个完整的操场
王心凌最常挂在嘴上的
当年的篮球场多么迷
你
如今已经变成花圃
但我们学校比较小
我们如果要运动会的话
会去借文化的大操场
运动会
OK这就是篮球场
这个花圃的大小就是我们的篮球场
你是觉得惊讶
是迷你到有点惊讶
以前坐在这边的时候
一下课探头就可以看到人家在打篮球
重回教室的王心凌看见黑板很自然
下一个动作是拿起粉笔写下
相当复古的到此一游
不过签名写日期却不小心
2003啊啊这什么车啊
诶这怎么会擦不掉啊
吃了哦
2003是我出道的
那你回到校园就不小心掉进时光隧道
其实另一个更复古的回忆是
王心凌12岁时参加综艺节目的影片
曾被挖出
一度在网络热议
原来唱跳细胞从小就养成
哈哈哈儿童舞蹈大赛
然后我妈说我就有一天看看看看看看看
就跟她说
妈妈我觉得我可以叫的比他们好
妈妈你帮我放好就可以跳
不知道哪里来的自信
而我们现在所认识的唱跳甜心女神王心凌
小时候的梦想却是小时候就是看电视
那时候还小嘛
然后就觉得林彦秋很对
很漂亮
很聪明
然后还有每日一次
所以那时候就会想
我说哇我想要当李艳秋
后来啊喜欢唱歌这件事
也是成为我后来的其中一个呃
兴趣跟梦想
小时候写着梦想的自己
长大后有没有长成理想中的人呢
本场40岁的过程也同时更认识了自己
其实我一点都不觉得奔四残酷诶
你会有很多学习的累积
智慧的累积就是怎么样让自己生活的老
去的优雅又自然是最重要的
其实挺舒服自在了好一阵子的
我觉得譬如说以前他只顾他自己
他把自己做好
可是现在他到一定成熟的阶段的时候
他才发现诶
这个灯光师他是不是要稍微休息一下诶
他好像刚刚没有吃饭哦
诶我都有下一条解话
七零现在会去KO旁边的这些人对
那或许他以前也有
但是他可能会不好意思讲
傅植被的黄忠平导演这么说
而合作多年又年纪相仿的化妆师与法师
既像闺蜜
又是密切工作伙伴
形容王心凌对细节极其讲究
我才是细节控啊
因为我跟心凌其实都一样
处女座
所以他讲的其实我都懂
这些细节就是为了陈志献给就是观众
就是一个完美的表演了一个完美的造型
有句话什么大糖浆魔鬼藏在细节里
越简单的东西它就是很难弄
我觉得在工作上规模其实是一个专业的表现
讲究细节
龟毛才是专业的表现
王心凌这一天回到校园
正逢台风到来的日子
顶个枪风
头发不时被吹乱
裙子也得时时顾好
女明星保持美丽是众人的努力
但是当王心凌参加乘风破浪的姐姐节目露营
这些伙伴都不在身边
看着节目
同时也欣赏着王心凌的转变
其实我蛮感动的
对
我就觉得哇他其实在这个节目是有成长
有进步的诶
他不一样了
就是这前面疫情这两年半
其实他有在升级
那这些称赞的话
你们会当面对他对啊
我们每天都在讲说哇
你好漂亮
万人不理解的
身边有人理解就可以
王心凌演艺圈这20年来经历不少风雨
光是过去两段感情的新闻版面就占了不少空间
一路看着他成长的前辈们
也道出不为人知的一面
我看过他两次在大家面前落泪
都是因为被误解而流下的眼泪
可能因为他很小就进入了这个行业
他其实这一路过来遭遇到蛮多的
不管是工作上面的私人
感情上面的各式各样的挫折也好
打击也好
我觉得他已经练就了一种从容去看待这些事情
我是属于乖巧的学生
乖艺人就是可以做的
我就是会努力走下来
本来30岁开始放慢脚步
那这一次就是乘风破浪回来
又有很多很多不同的机会
所以就还是用感恩的心继续前行
打从出道以来
甜蜜甜心等形容词套用在他身上
经过了20年
他坦言这不是人设
而是本职
因为以前说过
80岁就是如果我你们还想听我唱歌的话
那那那我就会我还是会唱
如果说80岁呃
我还跳得动的话
就是还可以就是拄着拐杖唱爱你
当甜心奶奶不是也不错嘛
被爱着是前进的动力
被人需要是幸福的
那个即使到了80岁
还愿意当个甜心奶奶的王心凌
用着全唐的浓度滋润着身边的人与歌名
你现在对自己作品的那个精益求精
你自己觉得会不会跟你合作的人都发现哇
你现在对于这个作品的期待非常的高
所以你愿意投资很长的这个时间来琢磨
其实后来自己都一直有参与专辑
然后其实参与专辑的时候
我们其实都是这样
然后就是说那精益求精的心情心态是一样的
不过真的就是本来昨天是要
本来昨天是要录完最后一首歌
然后真的也是因为那个歌词还是想要调整
所以后来还是没有录完
可是但我现在都会很正面的告诉自己
反正就是好事多磨
就是反正就是大家都是想把事情做好
这样其实你是很独立的人哦
观众朋友讲
刚刚我们在这个开录之前哎
因为我们要调整这个心灵的麦嘛哈
要呃换边别换边
别的时候这个歪头你就要重新打开诶
我跟你讲
这是我录了13年来
我第一次有来宾要换MAL时候
诶
没说什么
就自己自己拆开来
自己弄
自己重新上下
别的有了心灵是自己把那个麦头拆开
然后自己呃弄好了好了
可以了可以了可以了没有
我是看这个meal
我还会拆另外比较复杂的meal
我就无法了没有
我只是观察
他说这真的跟我在一准备要访问信零钱
我看到很多人说
其实你自己也说你是一个独立性很高的人
从哪些事情你愿意跟华人观众分享
你是一个独立性很高的人
对自己能做的事情都习惯自己做
其实我觉得我应该是因为我家庭环境的关系
所以某个部分来说我是独立的对
但是如果有有人可以依赖妈妈在的时候啊
哦就是或是表姐在所有人可以依赖的时候
我还是会依赖
可是因为环境的关系
我是长姐
我是姐姐
然后有一个小我五岁的弟弟
所以从小就是会比较独立的做事情
尤其我爸妈就是离异的状态嘛
所以有时候就要变小妈妈
所以某个程度有一些部分我是独立的
再加上
其实小时候拍戏的时候
很多东西也是自己来啦
那后来就是到浪姐的时候
就又开始就是什么都要做
就一身兼数职
就是什么要做
所以包含这些卖的这些事情
就是反正我就觉得反正这样比较快
没关系
我能来我就自己来
那我真的我们也做不来
就再麻烦你们这样
所以人生有时候他很像一个倒流
我听你讲
我感觉20岁时候出道的
你
其实你可能比一般人
相对在要判断和处理事情上要来的早熟一些
但现在40岁
每个人都说诶
你今天录音的时候
你帮我们仔细看看那个王兴
你会不会看起来真的像人家说的
像20岁
也没有那么夸张
我这人生是一个道理
以前你会觉得自己呃要比较早熟嘛
在小孩子的时候进入这一行
进入这一行其实就是懵懵懂懂边做边学
但是需要比较早熟
是因为家庭环境的关系
我们回到讲道结束
你说你其实你变得更独立了
因为那是一个争分夺秒的时间利用
对不对
是一个很新的经验
就觉得说嗯其实原来快40岁也可以
也可以被逼成这样
从第三季的浪姐
从王心凌心想里面去看
其实那个过程要多努力
在实践压缩上说
有时候忙到连麦克风都不能够拆下
都没有
这个时间要上厕所的时候
可以跟我们聊一下吗
这个过程我们每一次去进去露营
至少我这一期是讲就是大概三天三夜
五天五夜
有公演的那一段就是五天五夜
可是我觉得那个时间的利用
跟那个工作量根本是加倍的
所以你说五天当十天用的这种概念
差不多是这样
所以嗯然后这整个环境只有厕所跟换装间
没有尽头
然后只要有人在的地方
基本上那些机器都不会停止
它会收录你所有所有的音乐的声音
就算没有影响
但它有声音去去去利用
这样他是这么这么真实的一个呃
是这样的真人秀
然后所以你也不太会有机会可以放松
那我们要化妆
我们要呃练舞
要练歌
要开舞台
会议要定妆
要彩排
要拍杂志
就是那是三天三夜
五天五夜里面要做的很多很多很多的事情
所以其实我是我的朋友
参参与上一季的姐姐陈琳
就知道说最后你会就是会放弃才买
我要当王心凌艺人本领
我要当自己的助理
准备所有的东西
从under way安全裤袜子的长短
就是你工作所有需要用到的东西要自己准备
然后后来当队长
就是还要当变经纪人去协调大家的时间
然后我要解决我自己在舞台上
比如说呃队长突然会需要比别人多一首歌
就是我要解决我自己在表演上的一些问题
我要去处理之外
然后又是队长
还要去协助队友当一对一的私教课
教吴谨言小姐
因为她是演员
姐姐嘛
只要她唱歌
但因为她很努力
所以就是要做的事情真的很多对
但是我觉得这是不一样的一种体验吧
就因为时间的压缩
所以这个倍量是一个很新的经验
对是一个很新的经验
就觉得说嗯其实原来快40岁也可以
也可以被逼成这样
所以是这个挑战
我要说是很过瘾的一个部分
还是你发现你自己有这样你没有发现的潜能的
让你觉得很回味的一部分
我应该是说我觉得她是一个很特别的体验
然后还是会很回忆起就是过去的那段经历
不管是跟工作同事或者是跟之前的队友禁言
阿娇阿莎就是回忆起这些东西
其实都还是很开心
很美好的
我们到现在都还是私下会有群主
还是会联系
就是还是很珍惜这一份
曾经一起努力打拼了这个时光
但是我真的觉得就是可以的
就是带一次就够了的美好回忆对
然后呢
今天我还有一个问题是蜂蜜
大家叫我一定要问
第一个是说你坐在那个王心凌对面
你可以帮我们看清楚
他是不是真的看起来像20几岁
还有一个就是保养之道
因为我在看天下杂志访问姓名
然后他特别提到说王心凌很坦然的说
其实做甜心奶奶对我来讲也有什么不可以嗯
所以这个保养跟年龄对于你来说
你是怎么样的去看待跟全身保养
我觉得真的都是老生常谈
就是卸妆清洁
敷脸保湿
你的睡眠时间
大概你平均一天要让自己一定要睡到几小时
我从去年开始发现好的睡眠品质非常的重要
就是除去年时数要攻实数
我觉得是睡眠品质
有时候时速我们工作的关系就是很难抓
时速会有多少
可是睡眠的品质
我觉得对于身体的恢复来讲
我觉得有很明显的感受
你累的时候会不会失眠
因为大家想知道王兴你是不是跟跟你我一样
哈哈你累的时候会不会失眠
会说你钱你也会有会啊
我其实我其实去年从姐姐那个时候也常常失眠
到现在也常常失眠
是在想工作的事情
就是压力对
听不下来
所以我最近也是蛮长时间
所以才会觉得最近真的深的
深深觉得睡眠品质很重要好
所以他的分享了秘诀
就是这个你对年龄的看法呢
哦因为你经验很坦然的
所以我都到处可以看到听到诶
80岁的甜心奶奶也可以
你的年龄的看法是什么
我想这个对很多观众朋友来讲
他们也想听
你就是其实我像有些人说
你在不在意
说你的年龄
其实我不在意
因为就算我在意的话
大家网络上也都查得到
所以不如就坦然接受
而且我觉得本来就是年龄就是会这样
这是一件自然而然的事情
所以你应该是去坦然接受
去享受自己每一个年龄的变化
对啊
然后我希望我自己以后可以优雅的老去
我觉得是最重要
我们刚刚看过了
那个从小小时候出道到现在的板子
我觉得他就是一个实力的累积
然后实力本身带来很大的变化
我们来看一下这一次里面啊
王心凌合唱了一首歌
然后这首歌让很多
也许以前没有跟着王心凌走演艺路的人
才发现说哇心凌是真的会唱这首歌
是你跟谭会不会都是实力派唱将啊
那时候为什么会确定这个目标来挑战这首歌
它的难度其实不只是高音
对不对
我知道这首歌对于观众来讲其实很新鲜
就是很意想不到
对我来说也是挑战
可是其实我心里也知道
那是我可以驾驭有把握的挑战
然后上海这个公园是我所有公园里面
最轻松的一公
因为只需要好好唱歌
我觉得对于薇薇来讲
应该也是
因为我们在那之后
我们就是队长
然后可能还要准备两个舞台
两个表演
然后都要跳舞
这是这是唯一一次公演
我们可以好好好好面对一首歌曲
好好唱歌的一种哦
你刚刚有一句话很打动我
你说其实选这首歌
你知道你自己可以驾驭的
嗯嗯他带来这么多的惊喜
我惊喜里面还有很多人佩服说哦
原来他是可以唱这样一个难度
或者通俗讲哦
其实你可以飙到这么稳的这个高音
这个过程里面是不是很多人对于你的歌唱实力
或者其实你可以驾驭不同类型的歌曲表演
其实还没有这么的了解
所以就是也是很谢谢
就是去年这样的一段时光
让大家看到不一样的我
因为实际上就是在我的专辑里面
突然选一首这样子的歌曲
可能也会蛮跳痛
就是不太有机会唱到这样子的歌
然后反而是因为节目
所以你没有任何包袱的
可以去做不一样的表演
所以我们对这个演唱会的期待只有有身高
我就发现这个心灵是对任何挑战都举重若轻
处之泰然的人
甜心自从这个新名被封为甜心教主之后
这个词好像用在谁的身上有过吗
杨丞琳有没有被灌过甜心
在她初出道时我就会忘记可爱好可爱
那时很流行教主可爱教主
甜心甜甜心
甜蜜教主
百变教主
还有什么
那时候很流行教主对
只有这个甜心教主
到现在江湖上呢还是东方不败
哈哈甜心
这个有的人会觉得说啊
甜心限制了你
限制了我们对你的想象
事实上也不尽然
所以你对甜心今年好多访问里面有提到
你没有那么排斥甜心的这样的一个人设或形象
我觉得很大的重点是因为他不是我的人设
他是我的个性特质之一
我觉得不管别人理不理解你
你都可以喜欢自己
拥抱自己的特质
那这是我的特质之一
它不应该是我的包袱
所以这也是我觉得是不是你的一个
我觉得是一种很成熟的一个豁达
就是呃不因为别人怎么看你
你会觉得自己在这个框架里面去呈现自己
只要那个跟你自己的特质不违和就OK的对
其实在过程中我们也有做过很多不同的尝试
的确就是这些尝试
其实还是我还是不希望他不像我自己
我还是希望他不是违背王心凌这个人
而去尽力去做的尝试对
然后所以我们也唱了山海
因为山海让大家就是奥
王心凌也可以唱这样的歌
然后因为这个节目对这种真人秀的录制方式
会让大家看到我
私底下王欣怡其实是怎么样准备工作
准备舞台就是比较大家看不到的那一面
那另外一方面就是
其实你说你自己一直其实是希望做个有肩膀的
你刚刚提过你小时候照顾那个小你五岁的弟弟
你是真的就是有照顾他
就是说在他的生活起居上面
就因为呃本来父母没有离异的时候
所以有时候他们工作比较晚
那真的就是会要我要照顾弟弟
我其实五岁的时候
弟弟就是还是小婴儿
然后我就要在家里
但是一小段时间就是看顾着他
时间到了
我要跑上楼上去五楼找邻居太太帮我喂弟弟
喂喂喂
弟弟还没有像小姨没有对
然后后来我们家是在我小二
小三的时候离异离异
后来我跟弟弟就跟着妈妈
那妈妈还是要工作
所以我觉得有时候会像小妈妈这样子
然后然后就嗯自己试图煮菜这样
然后弟弟就会很贴心对我说好不好吃
他就说好吃
后来我想每次怎么都说好吃
后来就问他说
那你下次还想不想吃
就不想吃
我就知道那个是不好吃
小时候是因为这样子的环境就是还算蛮独立的
但我觉得有肩膀的人
其实像后来有时候跟弟弟在说
就是我觉得我们要懂得去为我们的选择呃
负责跟承担
然后遇到问题的时候
我们要有去面对和解决的能力
就是这是一种独立
这是一种独立
而且这是我觉得就是有肩膀的人
就是我其实自己是是这样子的人
所以从20岁就进入演艺圈
她绝对是一个相对复杂的行业跟环境
但是你刚刚讲说
既然你那时候自己选择了
所以后来你在碰到一些挑战甚至困难的时候哦
会比较不舒服的事情的时候
其实你是自己啊自己去承担
对不对
就是对自己的对选择去承担对
但但
反正我觉得感情啊
情感啊跟父母的爱
跟兄弟姐妹的爱
跟朋友的爱就是爱这件事情是是交流的
然后呃接收跟给予都很重要
因为刚才一开始你们没有听到
我想说我要把这四个字记下来
他刚刚讲的相互奔赴
我如果没有听错的话
我就非常喜欢这四个字
而且是我啊第一次在艺人的口里面听到
所以我觉得相互奔赴
应该也是他可以诠释你出道20年的心情
然后人生40岁这个阶段的心情也是面对世界
或是面对你所珍惜的人
希望都是一个啊爱的流动
都是一个相互奔赴的不对
所以这也是很多跟你想
会从你小时候跟你一起喜欢你
一直到现在的原因
其实你们有很多时间
真正的除了开演唱会时值的跟歌迷有有互动吧
一本在网络的时代对
虽然就是呃因为网络的时代
我可以看到很多他们的视频
或是他们会在我的朋友下面做一些留言
可是实际上很实质的交流
互动的确是没有这么多
但是我觉得他可他们可以从从我们在表演上
就是一些细节上
我们给予他们的反馈
我觉得他们会接收到我的歌迷
其实也是一直告诉我
他们有感受到我跟他们是在相互奔赴
然后互相陪伴
每次想对所有的艺术创作或者演艺工作人来说
最嗯跟歌迷最直接的互动去透过作品啊
这次有演唱会啊
心灵是喊出了最高规格全糖启动
在一起过20年的呼唤
那个糖是糖果的糖
好最高贵的全场启动
在今天我们的这类节目
最后
其实我们一起期待在演唱会呈现在我们面前
那当然有很多要属于保密的部分
怎么办呢
就希望将来有机会再邀请到心灵跟大家聊
可以谈一下
总的来说最高规格跟全糖启动
在这次疫情后的这个演唱会啊
你希望传递的是一个什么样的嗯
王心凌精神
还有跟歌迷
希望那个晚上是怎么样的一个气氛跟情景
这次的巡演的主题叫徐格海
当我的应该可以说吧
我专辑里面有一首歌就叫做sugar high
然后20周年
所以我希望大家都可以来呃
有一种庆祝的感觉
然后可以在这个晚上得到很多美好的回忆
跟一种放松对
然后一起庆祝我们的20周年好
这个蛋糕上的20蜡烛吹过之后再往下
在戏剧我们刚刚提到歌唱
在戏剧或演艺事业
其他各方面
你自己最新的想象是什么
最后可以跟我们分享一下
其实说真的
就是这次的新专辑跟接下来的巡演
已经排到明年了
所以其实新的巡演会占据这次工作
很大的很长的时间
但是至少到明年
所以戏剧真的是很久没有参与了
我现在也只能用一种就是随缘的心情好
欢迎大家在尝尝
回去寻找那个让你们难忘的微笑
帕斯塔或其他
在里面看到有一部分特质
依旧保有那个甜心不变的心灵
大家可以一直的回味
而且一直的关注现在心灵的发展
今天非常谢谢心灵来看板人物
谢谢期待演唱会
也期待你的专辑带给我们更多更多的感动更新
谢谢你
谢谢谢谢谢谢大家
谢谢
很开心
今天见到念华姐
今天和大家分享了那么多心里面的想法
接下来我有很多新的巡演会到呃
很多城市
希望大家都可以来看王心凌
2023苏哥海世界巡回演唱会20周年
希望大家都可以来一起庆祝参与我的喜悦